So what if you could not
use typeset languages?
You could not use languages like Java or
others that do this checking to prevent
all memory overflow kind of attacks.
What can we do in that case if you're
stuck with let's say languages for
whatever reason, we talked about a few,
where this is not done automatically,
what should we be doing?
So when we are using these so
called unsafe languages that
automatically don't prevent buffer
overflows then it become
the responsibility of the programmer.
If you're writing code it
is your responsibility
that you deal with this problem
of potential buffer overflows.
One way you can do that is
by checking ALL input, okay?
So secure coding mantra
is that trust no input.
All input is evil and
you should be checking
that it can conforms to
whatever your expectation was.
Don't rely on the underlying system to
do those because we're talking about
using languages that do
not do automatically.
So secure coding is an extremely
as you write programs.
You write them to implement
certain functionality.
You may even write them with some
performance goals in mind, but
at the same time you need to keep in
mind that you have to write them so
they cannot be exploited.
You have to code securely or
use secure coding practices so your
program doesn't have the vulnerabilities
like the ones we've been talking about.
And one way you do that
is by checking ALL input.
The other thing that you can do is,
you can use functions that
are safer that do bound checking.
So remember in the code we could
have string compare or string copy.
You could also have certain side string,
though you shouldn't be dealing with
a string that is longer than that.
So their functions that would place
a limit on the length of the string this
function would manipulate.
So you can use there number of
safer ways to use certain functions
that are unsafe and the patterns and
ways of using those that
are safer where the likelihood of
a vulnerability is a lot lower.
So these functions, all though the
language doesn't do it, the functions
that you do will do the checking or
the bounds checking that we're talking
about, and as a result using those leads
to code that is safer more secure.
And the last thing you can do after
written some code that's not in
a typeset language, is to use tools
that exist that would actually
analyze code that you have written and
flag potential vulnerability.
The way they able to do that is,
they can look for certain code patterns.
They can look for
certain unsafe functions, and
can warn you that the code fragment
that you have where these things appear,
an unsafe function appears,
could be potentially
vulnerable to some sort of exploit
buffer overflow or something like that.
So these tools, you just run your
code through these tools and
there's a lot of them
that are out there.
Some commercial,
some you can get for free.
And these tools they
rely on sort of database
of certain kind of patterns
that are known to be unsafe.
And if they run into your code that
matches those kind of patterns,
they can flag those.
And they can do more sophisticated
analysis to potentially discover
the kind of vulnerability
that we're talking about.
So there's no excuse for
writing code that is not secure.
You should be checking your input.
You should be using safer functions
that do that checking automatically.
And then you should run through
your coded through these tools
that can flag potential problem spots.
And you should go back and
look at that and
see how you can actually make those
potential vulnerabilities go away.
One problem with automatic tools
is that they may have a lot of
false positives or if they miss out and
they have false negatives.
So you can't have tools that will have
zero false positives or false negatives,
but the tools can certainly help
us get rid of many possible
vulnerabilities in the process producing
code that is a lot more secure.
So even when you are stuck with
programming in a language that's not
going to help you much with the kind of
attacks, vulnerabilities that we've been
talking about, there's certainly things
you can do as a programmer who likes to
do secure programming by checking input,
using safer functions, and
then running, checking your code through
these tools that we're talking about.
And we'll have a long list of these
tools actually you can go and
learn about.